bonjour nous sommes en retard julie va
chanter sa chanson
ça y est ça commence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
[Musique]
je voudrais faire
montrer
là
j'y vois les filles et les garçons
oh
casimir show de sa chanson
françois
vos jeux
[Musique]
mais je n'aurai mieux pas si je vais
vous la faune
mais j'aimerais mieux peu si j'étais à
l'enfant
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
dans le kiosque que les poupées
écoliers
couleur cerise
c
il
[Musique]
apa fillon passe temps
ainsi sur un bond de géant
[Musique]
utile m
non mais je me fais mieux pas si je
désire
si j'étais un enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
vous auriez aimé être un grand peintre
bas et mademoiselle julie métier-là et
oui j'aurais aimé faire de beaux dessins
riche en couleurs comme le font tous les
enfants comme les enfants et comme moi
ajimi artiste-peintre talent un temps un
petit peu l'artiste peintre j'ai une
lettre pour toi ô merci-facteur j'adore
recevoir des lettres
je veux bien l'ouvrir j'ai peur de la
régie renault est bien sûr
aussi c'est une lettre dans un zoo et
j'aime bien jouer lé maroc c'est une
personne très sympathique
voilà ce qu'elle met criant mon cher
casimir je vais venir car quelques
photos dans l'île aux enfants j'aurai
besoin que tu me trouves mans un poisson
rouge une souris blanches et en loin en
jaune plus les ingrédients pour faire
des photos sur la recette du
gloubiboulga je compte sur toi
amicalement aux oreilles mais c'est
formidable casimir tu vas devenir
l'assistant de la grande photographe zoé
pour que tout ça c'est très bien mais
moi j'ai ma tournée continuer et toi
casimir tu n'as pas de temps à perdre
les travail il faut que je trouve un
poisson rouge une souris blanches et un
ans aujourd'hui bon je me dépêche tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure que des villes
[Musique]
assez vous je croyais que c'était
quasiment
non il n'est pas encore là il doit avoir
du mal à trouver son poisson rouge sa
souris blanche et son oiseau jaune
oui si sa remue où il va pas tarder
revenu un peu plus tard
voilà
j'espère que vous êtes content
maintenant il ne nous manque rien et
vous ne pourrez plus vous plaindre alors
quasiment tu as trouvé ce que tu voulais
royan enfin presque
mais en effet donc ton poisson n'est pas
rouge ben non qu'on veut tu anatole le
poisson rouge joue à saute poisson chat
avec ses amis alors il n'a pas plus
lourd oui
mais ta souris devait être blanche oui
mais quand vas tu as
si donné la souris blanche a découvert
une sculpture en gruyère coffin monsieur
luce nord alors elle est partie avec
toutes ses amies
évidemment alors heureusement antoinette
qui s'est fait mal à la pâte a accepté
de venir bonjour antoinette
mais
l'oiseau il n'est pas jaune non plus des
toits il s'appelle jaune elle et il est
persuadé qu'il est jaune alors il ne
faut pas le décevoir bon vous m chers
amis bonjour massy le dise non à bas
vous vous portez bien monsieur d'isnor
merveilleusement ma chère amie bun finir
une sculpture dans un matériau encore
jamais utilisée l'un des rares
et comment le savez-vous comme ça on a
deviné où c'est extraordinaire parce que
juste l'annoncer des cours hier à vous
devriez venir la voix oui on viendra
puis d'en acheter que des tubes rien
j'en parlais de mon ami la souris
blanche mais parlons de souris je vois
les animaux en cage mettez scandaleux ça
s'est jamais vu dans les enfants shaya
vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit monsieur
du snob un scandale vous devriez avoir
honte
casimir je vois pas en quoi ces
malheureuses victimes devraient avoir
honte et pas toi comment mais au lieu de
venir gentiment posé pour les photos de
zoé ces animaux ont exigé d'avoir un
endroit pour se reposer et à boire à
manger et en plus il a fallu que je les
transporte ici moi même
pas vu le problème sous cet angle
voilà casimir tous les ingrédients pour
le gloubiboulga retard merci de m'avoir
aidé juillet
salut la marche comme sur des roulettes
poubelle je vous laisse travailler
dis donc elle travaille ça c'est du beau
travail quasiment à
bout
tiens poissons les parages ah bah non
non c'est grave non ce fait rien la
souris n'est pas blanche et l'oiseau
n'est pas les pages jaunes en photo puis
tout ça s'appelle important
elle s'en fiche
tant mieux pour toi
casimir c'est pour bobby boulga oui mais
attention il ne faut que deux bananes
mais fais attention enfin tu mets trop
de moutards de ramener ça fait rien tour
pour la photo s'en fiche ah bon on va
tout mélanger mais papa pas trop de
confiture non plus ça c'est rien ça
c'est rien
elle s'en fiche encore jeune j'ai le
temps de me faire du souci elle se fiche
de tout
voilà voilà
tiens kazimiyah un petit peu de
poussière à près de l'aquarium tu peux
l'enlever mais bien sûr
mais attention quoi tu as mis la
poussière sur mon objectif fort c'est
quand même pas pour deux ou trois grains
de poussière oui mon vieux c'est le
rater toutes mes photos bon bah alors
vite alors faut que j'aille essuyé mon
objectif maintenant aux
salorges je ne comprends plus rien elles
sont mortes de tours et puis soudain
pour à deux trois grains de poussière
elle se met en colère c'est normal
casimir chacun nous n'attache pas la
même importance aux choses c'est pour ça
que c'est si souvent difficile de
comprendre les autres ouais c'est vrai
arias
[Musique]